okay welcome back everybody so today
we're going to continue talking about
the numerical integration of OD es okay
we're going to code up the forward and
backward Euler schemes that we derived
in the last lecture and we're going to
try them out on two examples and look at
how accurate they are and how stable
they are okay so for numerical
integration the two things that we
always care about our accuracy and
stability okay and we're going to kind
of get to the bottom of what that means
in this lecture and then in the next two
lectures we're going to cook up way more
advanced integration schemes that are a
lot better than forward and backward
Euler and we're going to start applying
them to really really complicated Odie's
that are chaotic and we're going to look
at some kind of advanced topics that
probably most of you and you know
haven't seen before okay so just a
little bit of a refresher and please you
know feel free to interrupt at any time
so we have some differential equation X
dot equals f of X that we're going to
solve and usually kind of early on in
school solving this means writing
something down on the board or on your
paper in closed form but then we grow up
and we get real problems and real
problems can't be solved in closed form
okay so this was famously discovered in
fact the the word chaos basically means
that you can't write down a closed form
solution to this equation okay so at the
turn of the last century in 1906 there
was a contest that was held by I believe
the king of Sweden maybe not the king of
Sweden one of the kings a great king
essentially not the king of Sweden
essentially held a contest to see who
could solve the three-body problem okay
he loved astronomy he realized that most
of the great advances in technology and
science at that point had come from
astronomy okay telescopes and physics
and Newton's laws in the whole bit and
so he thought that this is the
next unsolved problem in astrophysics
was the three-body problem what happens
when you put three massive objects in
space and let them interact right
shouldn't be too hard of a problem the
two-body problem was solved by Kepler
hundreds of years earlier
so he said okay anyone who solves the
three-body problem gets riches and fame
x' and i'll fund your lab forever
basically
so Henry Poincare a most of you have
probably heard the name Poincare a at
some point famously discovered that for
the three-body problem this is one of
the simplest simplest problems you can
write down in physics I literally have
the Sun Jupiter and Saturn and I let
them just do what they will and Poincare
a discovered that you can't write down a
solution there is no way there's no
amount of paper or pencil that you can
write down the solution to this system
of equations and moreover if you perturb
any of the variables or masses or
positions by a tiny little epsilon the
solution changes kind of exponentially
far from the original solution as you
evolve in time okay and he discovered
chaos so most real systems you can't
write down a closed-form solution for
it's hopeless
we will never write down a closed-form
solution to most systems that we care
about and so when I say solve a system I
mean find some way of numerically
representing the solutions of this
system in a way that we gain and
understanding about the engineering
system how to design it how to change it
how to choose initial conditions how to
control it okay it's a little bit of a
historical aside but I really want to
emphasize that even very very simple
systems are often chaotic or nasty or
hard to represent okay okay so just kind
of a review of what we did last time so
we had two schemes that we cooked up the
forward Euler it's not Euler its Euler
forward Euler is XK plus 1 equals XK
plus delta T
F of XK okay so I have to choose a time
step for this numerical integration and
I'm going to take my state at some time
TK and I'm going to advance it to time
TK plus 1 which is delta T in the future
and I'm going to keep doing that over
and over and over again and this defines
a trajectory or a numerical solution to
my OD if we were really lucky and our
differential equation was a matrix
linear system of differential equations
which we actually can solve then we
would write this as X we would write
this as the identity plus delta T times
our a matrix times XK forward Euler ok
and then we also have backward Euler
which is a slightly more clever scheme
but it's also not just slightly it's
much harder to implement for nonlinear
systems ok so this one we have X of K
plus 1 equals XK plus delta T f of XK
plus 1 seems like a really really subtle
distinction right I just changed the
subscript index of the function of XK
plus 1 here but what that means is that
now my future state XK plus 1 is
implicitly defined which makes it really
really hard to solve for again unless my
systems linear in which case I have
something like AI minus delta T a
inverse times XK ok any questions so far
this is just a review at this point but
important stuff
okay so there's two things I want you to
be thinking about I want you to be
thinking about
accuracy to sees accuracy as two CS yeah
it seems strange but when you're in
front of a board you can't spell
anything so accuracy and stability and
so what I'm gonna do first is I'm going
to talk about accuracy okay we're going
to actually code this up we're going to
see how it performs but in the back of
your minds I want you to be thinking
about the problem of stability and the
way we're going to think about this is
as follows this scheme is an iteration
okay so I have X 1 and I can get X 2 by
multiplying with the matrix and if I
have X 2 I get X 3 by multiplying with
the same matrix and X 4 by multiplying
with the same matrix so let's think
about a general iteration XK plus 1
equals some matrix M times X K that's
what we have here this is just some
matrix M and this is just some matrix M
and so what that allows us to do is it
allows us to take our initial condition
and go to some state at Delta T in the
future and then we can go to some other
state delta T get to Delta T in the
future and three Delta T in the future
and so on and so forth
it's probably just got a lot easier okay
and so we have X naught M X naught right
X 1 is just M times X naught X 2 is M
Squared X naught X 3 is M cubed X naught
and so on so that X n is M to the power
n X naught so at least for linear
systems which is where we can do
stability analysis mathematically we
have some iteration equation where if we
know some initial condition we can solve
for the trajectory by multiplying by the
same matrix over and over again so I
want you to be thinking about under what
conditions this trajectory is stable and
converges to 0 or is unstable and Diver
is from zero just in the back of your
minds okay okay so let's actually code
these up for a simple example and think
about accuracy and we're going to
revisit the stability problem after we
do some numerical simulations so the
problem that we're going to solve is the
spring mass damper okay so we have a
spring and a damper attached to a mass M
the position X is going to be the
displacement from equilibrium and I'm
going to skip all of the derivation
because we've already done this and I'm
just going to write down the equation we
have X double dot plus 2 Zeta Omega
naught X dot plus Omega naught squared x
equals 0
ok I've introduced these super fancy
Greek letters here Zeta is just the
damping ratio some spring constant
divided by sorry this is the damping
constant divided by 2 times the spring
constant mass square root doesn't really
matter and Omega naught is the natural
frequency square root of the spring
constant divided by the mass just these
are just numbers ok this is the damping
ratio this is the natural frequency of
the system this is a convenient way of
writing the system and so we can write
this as a system of first-order
equations like before and we get D DT of
X and V equals 0 1 ok so X dot equals V
and V dot equals minus this minus that
ok which is I think minus Omega naught
squared minus 2 Zeta Omega naught times
X and V I'm going fast because we've
already written this equation lots and
lots of times I just am introducing
different constants because I like this
parameterization of the problem better
than mass and spring constant ok these
are like this is a physic
parameterisation okay great we have an a
matrix and we're gonna solve this using
forward Euler and backward Euler okay
any questions about the derivation
Before we jump into MATLAB okay this is
not engineering mess okay good so we're
going to code up our example and we're
going to do it for a couple of different
cases we're gonna do it for the case of
an overdamped system and an under damped
system so that we get you know nice
undamped oscillations and we're going to
see how the stability of our algorithm
goes okay so we're going to clear all
I'm going to define my parameters like
the natural frequency is going to be two
pi the damping ratio is going to be one
point seven five and I'm going to define
my a matrix is zero one minus W squared
minus two times D times W okay in MATLAB
my Zeta variable is just D because I
don't want to type Zeta
okay okay DT is let's just pick a dt of
0.1 it's small but it's not too small
okay so this will kind of have some
inaccuracy that we'll see and let's
integrate from zero to ten in increments
of 0.1 so I should probably comment my
code this is an initial condition
sorry not an initial condition this is
the amount of time to integrate okay
this is my time step a matrix okay
and now my initial condition X naught is
going to be to 0 which I think I've used
before
so 2-0 what is this initial condition
physically correspond to in the spring
mass system okay I take this mass I pull
it two units of position off of
equilibrium and I let it go with zero
velocity I don't push it
I don't pull it I just I pull it to two
units off and I let it go
and what's going to happen and oscillate
and it's going to die out eventually and
go back to equilibrium okay and the
oscillation frequency is determined by
Omega and how fast it damps out is
determined by how big this D is bigger
do you faster damping I think should be
okay so now we're going to iterate our
forward Euler scheme okay and there's a
couple ways to do this how do I want to
do this so my initial condition is a
column vector right two : zero it's a
column vector so what I'm going to do is
every time I iterate my forward Euler's
scheme I go from X naught to X 1 to X 2
and so on I'm going to tack on a new
column vector into a big matrix so I'm
going to make a big matrix and that big
matrix is going to have a ton of column
vectors with two elements in each column
vector and that's going to be my
trajectory in time so as you read this
matrix from left to right that's going
to be time advancing okay so I'm going
to call it X F because we're doing
forward Euler and the first column of X
F you know : comma 1 is equal to my X
naught my initial condition okay and I'm
also going to keep track of my vector of
time and say that at time 1 its time 0
so I'm going to have a vector of time
starting at 0 and I'm going to add delta
T 2 at every step okay so for I equals
1/2 Big T divided by delta T this is how
many time steps I'm going to take
so I'm going to go up to a duration of
ten in increments of 0.1 then I'm going
to say okay well my new time is my eye
times DT and my position is equal to so
my new column vector of my state is
going to be identity plus a delta T
times my old state that's this formula
right here okay so X F at the next time
step is identity plus delta T a times my
old state so that's identity 2x2 plus a
delta T times my old state the ice
column should I change this to K's with
caves be better I use Kaizen all of my
math that would be fine we can just say
this is K okay here we go we have a few
more these are all K's okay
this is the exact same notation that
we're using here so we're counting up
our time index K and the k plus 1 state
depends on the cave state according to
this formula and that's mess that up and
that's it that's forward Euler okay any
questions about the implementation of
this before we run it
No okay maybe I'll run it and then
you'll have questions and then we want
to plot some stuff right so I want to
plot my time versus my state and I just
want the first position of my state not
the velocity so I'm just going to plot
the first row in black X label as time Y
label is position hold on
ah this is a a sim mass okay
okay so this is you know my I started at
a really big initial displacement I let
it go and it's damping out exponentially
and on top of that exponential damping
there is an oscillation this isn't
exactly what I pictured let's see maybe
I'll try a little bit less damping and a
smaller initial condition
oh that's unstable that's terrible okay
so my numerical scheme thinks that the
solution is blowing up to infinity but
we know that that's not actually
happening in the physics right if we
solve for the eigen values they would be
stable left half-plane
I can value so this is bad I'm going to
add more damping that was the wrong
direction
okay so let's try a different scheme I
don't think forward Euler is working
very well okay so for backward Euler
we're going to do the same thing we're
going to say we're going to have this
big matrix that is keeping track of our
state in time the first column is X not
my first time point is 0 and for K
equals 1/2 T divided by delta T TB of K
plus 1 equals ka VT and xB of the k plus
1 column so the K plus ones column of my
state is going to depend on the case
column according to I minus Delta ta
inverse so let's see in of a 2 by 2
identity minus a delta T times xB colon
comma K
okay and I'm gonna make my damping let's
try let's try one okay so the black
curve was forward Euler the red curve is
backward Euler let's see if I make this
like 0.75 trying to get some interesting
behavior here without killing my system
let's try this
okay so I have decreased my damping so
that this is an under damped system so
we would expect kind of damped
oscillations but you know still seeing
oscillations and we see let me put a
legend up we have forward Euler and
backward Euler ok so forward Euler
appears to think that the system is a
lot less stable right it's a lot more
ringy that means it's a lot closer to
instability and the red solution
backward Euler is a lot more damped okay
so how would I tell which of these
solutions is true what do I do to see if
these are like what's actually true
sorry we think the gum baby ended up
being in the thing okay so we could take
a numerical case where we know that the
system is critically damped and see what
it does what are some other things we
can do with our numerical schemes let's
say that I didn't know what the solution
of this was
sorry okay I could check the eigenvalues
let's say that this was a system where I
didn't even have an a matrix this is
just you know some system I integrated
what would I do to get a more accurate
solution you could try to cook up a
better scheme you know for the
derivative using central difference or
something like that I mean this is
simpler okay this is based on the the
finite difference derivative for X dots
and how do you make that derivative a
better approximation make Delta T's
smaller right so I could decrease delta
T in both of these cases and they should
get closer to each other hopefully so
let's try that let's try making delta T
0.01 this is going to take a while okay
good and they're agreeing much better
right
make delta T smaller and they agree a
lot better and we see that backward
Euler was more accurate all along right
this is more of a backward Euler looked
like even for a bigger DT something else
we can do is we can try using OD e45
okay so OD 45 is way way way more
accurate than either of these two
schemes and this is going to be kind of
our truth measurement for a little while
at least for non chaotic systems so
we're going to integrate this also using
OD 45 and just see how it compares so
for OD 45
we've done this before the outputs our
time and my state X and it's equal to OD
45 of a function of T comma X of a times
X from 0 and increments of DT to big T
starting at X naught remember OD 45
takes in three inputs some function to
integrate the right hand side of X dot
equals f of X some time span to
integrate through and some initial
condition X naught and we have all of
those things
okay and now I need to plot it so I'm
going to plot T by X first column and
instead of being row oriented OD 45
gives me two really long columns and I'm
going to plot that in blue
okay there we go so the true solution
the ode45 solution is this blue curve
and we see that for a big course DT of
0.1 both forward and backward Euler get
it wrong but they get it wrong in
different ways
okay so backward Euler has a ton of
inaccuracy it gets the time constants
all wrong and so does forward Euler but
forward Euler is more unstable when it
does it it's more ringy it's closer to
going on stable ok any questions about
the matlab code or the interpretation of
these plots or what the numerical
integration is doing ok big picture
forward Euler is less stable we'll see
why in a minute both forward and
backward backward Euler are pretty
inaccurate but we can make them more
accurate by decreasing the DT ok let's
just run this with a smaller DT one more
time ok for a smaller DT of 0.01 they
all agree much much better with the
fourth order integrator OD 45 ok we'll
come back to MATLAB a bit later but
let's do a little bit more math ok good
so now what we're going to talk about
our accuracy and stability from a
mathematical standpoint on a simple
linear system where we know what the
answer is okay so the spring mass damper
system the reason we're simulating this
and not jumping into some really nasty
chaotic problem is that this system is
linear and we know exactly what it's
supposed to do so we know exactly how
wrong our forward and backward Euler
schemes are at every time step ok
so in the course notes there is a small
discussion explaining what the accuracy
of these two methods are and this is not
a numerical analysis class and I'm not
going to cover this right now but you
can go look at it and see for yourself
why these things are true I'm just going
to write down a summary of what the what
the answers are so okay so for accuracy
we have forward Euler and backward Euler
and let's say we also have runge-kutta
sorry OD 45 okay and then again we have
the local and global error so remember
we talked about local versus global
error last time in the case of numerical
integration okay so forward Euler and
backward Euler both have a local error
of order delta T squared okay meaning
every single time you do this iteration
of forward and backward Euler you pick
up a little delta T squared error term
okay you could figure this out by doing
some Taylor series expansion and it's
all on the notes I'm not going to go
into it so if I want to make this local
error better I decrease delta T right if
I want it to be a hundred times better I
make delta T ten times smaller but if I
make my delta T ten times smaller I have
to take ten times more steps and so my
global error is order delta T so that
makes sense I mean I didn't explain why
this is order delta T squared but if you
take my word that it is then every
little every time you step forward this
trajectory you pick up a delta T squared
and you have about one over delta T of
the
use time steps okay so that global error
is delta T Oh de 45 the built-in MATLAB
command that we've been using has a
local error of I think about Delta T to
the fifth which means that its global
error is about Delta T to the fourth I
say about because it does some funny
things so it's not a fixed time step
integrator but in its in the ballpark of
a delta T to the fourth order accurate
integrator okay which I mean compare the
differences between these right if I
want my integrator to be 10,000 times
more accurate for forward and backward
Euler I need to take 10,000 times more
time steps for OD 45 I just need to take
10 more time steps kind of amazing okay
so it's way way way better scaling so OD
45 is kind of our all-purpose integrator
it's not the best one in the book but
it's very good its standard it's easy
and it's built-in so we're going to
always use that as kind of our first
attempt integrator and unless we need
something better we're going to use OD
45 okay good that's what I want to say
about error now I want to talk about
stability and I want to go a little more
into depth about stability because this
is kind of important and it's also
something that we're prepared to really
understand now that we know about
eigenvalues and eigenvectors okay
so when we're talking about stability we
can only analyze stability for the case
of linear dynamics X dot equals a times
X and in that case we know that our
iteration equation for this trajectory
is essentially just multiplication by
some matrix M ok now this is a little
tricky and I want to say this a couple
times because it's really important to
okay so when we had continuous time so
for continuous OD ease like X dot equals
a times X what is this solution stable
so I'm going to say stable when what the
eigenvalues of a have negative real part
so in the eggs of a when the real part
of the eyes of a are less than zero
meaning I have some complex plane where
all my eigenvalues live and they're all
in the left half plane they all have
negative real part the first eigenvalue
that crosses over into the positive real
half plane so that this real part of the
eigenvalue is positive makes my system
have exponential growth okay any
eigenvalues on the right half plane will
cause an unstable system so for
stability it's only when all of the
eigenvalues are in the left half plane
okay there's a slightly different
situation for this discrete-time system
by calling it discrete time because
we're calculating our trajectory
discrete Delta T's so for discrete I'm
going to call it it's not really an Eau
de but for discrete iteration equation
like XK plus 1 equals M X K this is
stable when anybody know when this
discrete system is stable how many of
you have seen this before and have some
idea of when the system is stable ok how
many of you don't know and are wondering
why I'm holding out on you ok so in this
equation here we know that our solution
is X naught M X naught M squared X
naught M cubed x naught thought thought
thought thought thought we just
multiplied by M more and more and more
now let's say that M M is a matrix so it
has eigenvalues and eigenvectors so I
can write m as t d t inverse just like
we could do with a except now I'm not
taking eetu the M I'm taking em to the
nth power I'm not I'm not exponentiating
this matrix M I'm just taking like a
multiple powers of M so M to the power
you know K is T D to the K T inverse
what is this matrix going to get really
ridiculously large when any of these
diagonal eigenvalues are bigger than 1
and when is this going to be really
really really small when all of my
eigenvalues in d are have magnitude less
than 1 I'm going to write it down then
we're going to say it one more time so
this is stable when all eggs of M have
lengths in the complex plane less than 1
so there's this unit circle in the
complex plane where if I'm at one or I
or square root of 2 over 2 1 plus I I
have unit length this is the unit circle
in the complex plane and as long as all
of my eigenvalues are inside this unit
circle then M to the K limit as K goes
to infinity equals 0
ok this M to the K will converge to 0 as
long as all of its eigenvalues are
inside the unit circle this kind of
makes sense like let's look at this M K
equals T DT inverse and ideas to the
power K so D is a matrix lambda 1 to the
K lambda 2 to the K dot dot dot lambda n
to the K zeroes everywhere else
that's what this is and if any one of
these lambdas is bigger than 1 then this
blows up to infinity as K goes to
infinity so let's try lambda equals 1
point 1 what's 1 point 1 to the thousand
power
I don't know the answer it's huge it's
really really huge right one point one
times one point one is one point two one
times another one point one is one point
three and so on it keeps adding and
adding and adding so this goes to
infinity as the power k goes to infinity
let's try lambda equals 0.9 what if I
take point nine to the thousandth power
basically zero right point nine squared
is 0.8 one that's smaller times another
point nine is 0.72 that's smaller and it
just gets smaller and smaller and
smaller and this goes to zero okay so
this iteration will go to zero as long
as all of the eigenvalues of m have
magnitude less than one in the in the
complex plane if any of them is outside
of here then this eigenvalue will cause
my numerical solution to go to infinity
which is what we saw in the numerical
example right my my numerix thought that
the spring mass was going to infinity
even when the continuous system was
stable okay
I'd like to pause for questions at this
point because the next part is going to
be deeper so yeah oscillate out to
infinity
that's exactly right if lambda was
negative one point one so it's at over
here but outside the unit circle the
magnitude would keep getting bigger and
bigger and bigger but the sign is going
to flip and if I met some theta with a
maximum at some angle with a magnitude
greater than one then I'm going as I
square in cube and quadruple M my
magnitude is going to increase and I'm
going to pick up that additional angle
every time I multiply that's how complex
numbers work right if I have if I have
some lambda equals magnitude e to the I
theta that's like this point here the
length is R and this is Theta then
lambda to the nth power is R to the N e
to the I and
so I pick up n of those Thetas and my
radius is take taken to the nth power
yeah good question okay other questions
yeah Allah only would work in the case
where the OD you can hear the this
analysis is only simple when my OD u is
linear because this this is only a
matrix M when my original OD u is linear
yeah exactly good question
and what we saw is that it's possible to
have a true system that is actually
stable but where our numerical solution
is unstable so we're going to see how
that could possibly be true now are
there any other questions about when
this discrete-time system is stable
though this essentially makes sense I
keep multiplying by M it gets really big
if any of my eigenvalues have magnitude
bigger than one and it gets really small
at that magnitude less than one okay so
we're going to analyze these stability
and I think that's probably all we're
going to have time for today and then
we're going to start solving problems
that are so complicated we can't really
think about stability except as a
cartoon using these examples okay so
let's take let's just do a full a full
example from scratch okay and I'm going
to do it on the simplest linear
one-dimensional one variable OD e I can
think of because this is still
complicated so our example is going to
be I'm calling this Y Y dot equals
lambda Y one variable linear the
solution is e to the lambda T and we
have some initial condition Y of zero
equals y naught okay so forward Euler so
it's so first of all this is stable
if the real part of lambda is less than
zero
okay so forward Euler is YK plus one
equals so identity plus a delta T is
just one plus delta T lambda times y K
okay backward Euler is YK plus 1 equals
okay was the inverse of identity minus a
delta T but these are just numbers so
it's 1 minus delta T lambda inverse x YK
pretty simple right forward and backward
Euler ok so forward Euler we have this
trajectory why not goes to Y 1 goes to Y
2 goes to dot dot dot to Y N and this yn
is this number to the nth power times y
naught ok
so Y n equals 1 plus delta T lambda to
the nth power times y naught this is
essentially my matrix M if M was just a
number and similarly for backward Euler
we have y n equals 1 plus Delta to 1
minus delta T lambda to the minus n of
power why not
that's my M to the nth power
questions about this derivation
literally just taking this linear
one-dimensional OD E and implementing
forward and backward Euler and then just
seeing like what happens after n
iterations okay and I want to know does
this system blow up or shrink to zero so
now what we're going to do is we're
going to say let's imagine that lambda
really is a stable eigenvalue so let's
say that lambda has a real part that's
negative so that this definitely should
be stable and the solution should go to
zero all right so our system is stable
the solution should go to zero now we're
going to see when these numerical
solutions are stable and go to zero okay
so okay so what is forward Euler stable
stable if and only if
so it's stable if and only if this
number has magnitude less than 1 in the
complex plane so it's stable if and only
if the length of 1 plus delta T lambda
is less than 1 in the complex plane
which is just another way of saying
unstable if 1 plus lambda delta T is
greater than 1 neutrally stable if it's
equal to 1 and backward Euler is stable
if this thing has magnitude sorry this
thing to the negative 1 has magnitude
less than 1 in the complex plane 1 plus
Delta t 1 minus delta T lambda to the
negative 1 power is this and unstable if
1 minus delta T lambda to the negative 1
power is bigger than 1 in the complex
plane ok so this is a little bit nasty
mathematically but basically what we're
seeing is for this linear system that
I've chosen to be stable there are Delta
T's that could make the numerical
integration scheme stable but there's
also Delta T's that could make this go
unstable numerically our simulation
could go unstable even though my real
system is stable if I choose my delta T
so that this number is bigger than 1 ok
which is a little scary that means that
we can't trust our numerix always we
can't like you could never trust your
numerix without doing some verification
ok all right so let's look at what this
how this looks in the complex plane so
we're going to say ok so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to fix my delta T and
we're going to look at for what lambda
this system is actually stable and this
will probably require a little bit of
verification okay so for forward Euler
and for backward Euler what we're going
to do is we're going to assume that
delta T lambda equals some complex
variable Z so 1 plus Z has to have
magnitude inside the unit circle for
forward Euler to be stable ok so what
that means is that my numerical
integration is only stable if Z is in
this very small circle and it's unstable
everywhere else so delta T times lambda
if it happens to be in this very small
unit circle centered around negative 1
then my numerical scheme will be stable
but for any other Delta T times lambda
my numerical scheme will be unstable
even if lambda is negative which is bad
this is terrible this is really bad out
here this is a bad no-man's land where
lots of people's codes live ok
backward Euler is a little bit better it
turns out that most of space is stable
so if your Z your delta T times lambda
lives anywhere out here you happen to be
stable which is good and there's this
little island of instability out here
which is really bad so even for backward
Euler there are some unfortunate choices
of delta T if your delta T is too large
then your system will become unstable so
what I want you to do to verify this on
your own this is first of all really
important and I don't have kind of a
whole class to tell you all about
numerical stability of integrators but
this is very important at some point in
your careers everyone's going to be
doing numerical integration and you
should know when your answer is accurate
or not whether or not it's stable you
want to know if your simulation is
stable and your system stable or if
maybe your simulation is disagreeing
with the real system because you're
having a bad a bad integrator so a kind
of upshot is if I start with a stable
integrator and I increase my delta T it
will make my system go unstable that's
true for all forward Euler schemes if
you take if you take a forward Euler
scheme with a stable delta T and you
just start ratcheting that delta T up
you will go into this unstable region so
it's kind of defined by large delta T
this is also defined by large delta T so
ratcheting up your delta T will also
cause backward Euler to go unstable but
because it's 1 minus delta T lambda
inverse its relegated to this relatively
small portion of the complex plane okay
that's it for stability next time we're
going to start doing real simulations on
chaotic system use using good
integrators thank you